Video game fans have plenty of questions about
the movie adaptation of "Uncharted."
For one, did Tom Holland really pull off the
role of Nathan Drake?
Even after seeing the film, some questions
will linger.
Keep watching for the biggest.
After being caught breaking and entering and
threatened with prison, Nate's brother Sam
escapes from the orphanage where the brothers
live.
Sam promises he'll come back, but he never
does, leaving Nate to wonder where Sam went.
Nate's mentor Victor "Sully" Sullivan admits
that Sam used to be his treasure-hunting partner,
yet he avoids talking about Sam's fate for
most of the film.
"I think you're here because of your brother."
"Wait, you know my brother Sam?"
Eventually it becomes clear that Sully and
his sometimes ally Chloe believe Sam is dead.
The mercenary Braddock even indicates she's
the one who killed him.
At the end of the film, though, there's a
brief scene set in a dingy prison that indicates
Sam is still kicking.
We see a man writing a postcard, the form
of communication he used to reach out to Nate.
But where is he, and how did he survive if
Sully, Chloe, and Braddock all thought they
saw him die?
There are several tantalizing ways that Nate
and Sully could learn about Sam's situation.
They could find out from a third party and
rescue him.
Nate could find out Sully secretly knows the
truth about Sam, leading to a rift.
Or Sam could escape and seek out the pair
in some unexpected way.
There's plenty of fodder for a sequel.
"Uncharted" makes it seem as though Santiago
Moncada is the film's main villain, but when
Braddock, the mercenary he hired, kills him
midway through the film, she becomes the true
antagonist.
Moncada was willing to do whatever it took
to find and claim Magellan's treasure, but
he didn't like to get his hands dirty.
Braddock, on the other hand, is more than
happy to get her hands dirty, and has a band
of goons who seem to share her cutthroat impulses.
That doesn't mean she's a great villain.
Her motivations mostly seem to revolve around
the desire for a massive payday.
Still, she keeps the film's fight scenes interesting,
including in the final fight on one of Magellan's
ships.
When she loses the fight and falls into the
ocean, that ship ends up crashing into the
water on top of her.
Given the circumstances, it seems like Braddock
must have died on contact, but there are plenty
of movies that have made it seem like the
villain is dead only to resurrect them in
the sequel.
If, say, Braddock was a strong swimmer, she
could have gotten away before the ship hit
the sea and we wouldn't have seen it.
The movie's mid-credits sequence sets up Nate
and Sully's next adventure.
Nate meets a man with an eyepatch to make
a trade to acquire a map that will lead to
Nazi treasure, although it's never clear what,
specifically, he's hoping to find.
In World War II, the Nazis confiscated and
looted all kinds of valuable art and artifacts,
so it wouldn't be all that surprising if Nate
and Sully decided to go after one of those
treasures.
Besides, Nazis come up a couple times during
the "Uncharted" games, so it's possible their
mention in the mid-credits scene is an indication
that, although this "Uncharted" film told
an original story, the plot of the sequel
will take its cues from the plot of one of
the games.
Either way, going up against Nazis is a popular
trope in action-adventure films.
Everyone from Indiana Jones to Captain America
have done it, so perhaps it's no surprise
that Nathan Drake and Sully would do so as
well.
The man that Nate meets in the mid-credits
scene references his boss during their exchange.
We don't know much about this boss, but one
of the things he requests in exchange for
the Nazi map is the ring Nate wears on a strap
around his neck.
The ring has sentimental value for Nate: It
was originally Sam's, and Sam gave it to Nate
when he left.
Yet as Nate points out, it has no real-world
value.
The man with the eyepatch's boss isn't seeking
financial gain, though.
His boss wants it because it has value to
Nate.
It seems as though this unseen boss could
be an interesting antagonist.
Of course, it's unclear whether he will be
the main villain in the next movie, as Nate
and Sully could find themselves racing against
someone else to claim the treasure.
Yet the fact that this boss is still unknown
indicates he could be a big player in the
next film.
Could this be a villain from the "Uncharted"
games?
Or maybe it's Sam himself.
After all, if Sam escaped from prison and
amassed his own gang, it could explain why
the man with the eyepatch said his boss wanted
Nate's ring.
In the last moments of the mid-credits scene,
Sully shows up to help Nate when the meeting
with the man with the eyepatch goes south.
After Sully gets the situation under control,
Nate and Sully leave together.
They bicker about Sully's delayed arrival
until they see something that stops them in
their tracks.
The final second of the film shows them looking
dumbfounded.
But what do they see?
It's entirely possible that they've run into
a new character or characters that we won't
meet until the sequel.
Or they may have encountered a character we're
familiar with.
Perhaps Braddock really is alive and has finally
hunted them down.
Or perhaps this is the point where Sam reveals
he's still among the living.
There are a ton of possibilities, but without
an idea of the potential story for the sequel,
it's hard to narrow them down.
"What else aren't you telling me?"
Sully summons Chloe Fraser when he and Nate
first arrive in Spain.
Even though Chloe initially antagonizes them,
they eventually team up to track down a map
to help them find Magellan's gold.
Nate and Sully quickly learn she wasn't entirely
trustworthy; she was actually working for
Moncada, and she regularly makes it clear
that she doesn't trust anyone.
Even so, she eventually helps them reclaim
the artifacts they need from Moncada's plane.
By the time Nate figures out the location
of the treasure, he knows he can't trust Chloe.
So he leaves a set of fake coordinates just
in case she takes off before he wakes up.
Unfortunately for Chloe, she takes the bait,
which means instead of finding the gold with
him, she goes on a wild goose chase.
The movie gives no indication of what that
means for her relationship with Nate or Sully,
leaving open the question of what could happen
if she ever meets up with them again.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.